another gruesome discovery in an already
disturbing case nye county deputies say
they have found dozens of frozen puppies
as they investigate this animal cruelty
case there this follows the seizure of
some 300 dogs found living in unsanitary
conditions at properties in amargosa
valley and pahrump since last week those
dogs have received around the clock care
they're all looking better just by
eating we're seeing a significant change
in behavior we're seeing a significant
improvement in their physical being
in general i think the time and food and
water and care is working out for them
in fact this morning nye county put out
some video showing the animals being
removed from the property and sent to
shelters meanwhile the two people you
see there oksana higgins and vasily
platinov they both face criminal charges
in this case they were in court
yesterday in a civil matter another
court appearance is set for next month
and again here is the video i just
referenced this is the sheriff's office
from nike county this is video posted on
the facebook page
in amargosa valley these dogs are being
moved to the county animal shelter
that's the captain from nye county who
we just interviewed the sheriff's office
hopes to move all of the dogs out of
that property by the end of the day